three two one
I'm here I'm here oh just one second let
me catch my breath once upon a time then
roast us the most Magical Kingdom
founded by a king with the power to
grant wishes you are the handsomest most
beloved King you're right I am a
handsome king
I'm so nervous I think I'm going to
explode my best friend the king's
Apprentice oh my mouth trooping I feel
like they're scooping
Asha come with me do
SE of roses wow people give their wishes
to me and I read the wishes I am sure
are good for Roses some of these will
never be granted that's some most they
deserve more than I decide what everyone
deserves
[Music]
so I look up at the stars to guide me I
wish
caution to every warning sign
[Music]
oh you spoil us with your magic I didn't
do it what
last night I made a wish on a star
uh and the star answered
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm talking I am talking who knew my
voice would be this low I believe I've
just been threatened who would dare
threaten you
I have no response to that
there is a traitor amongst us find us
it's a dead end with unsanded mahogany
here oh
good fine Valentino my butt found it
I started this I have to finish it
what are you hiding nothing
and nobody what is going on in there
okay ladies your wings can't fly but
your voices
oh